breaking developments to write tonight
surrounding the corruption foreign
business syndicate as we call because a
brand new email obtained by fox news
shows zero experience hunter he was told
in 2017 he had to amend his tax
forms because he failed to disclose
around 400 grand in
income from corrupt burisma holdings and
that's not all as a new subpoena
connected to the ongoing federal
investigation is demanding documents
related to more than
two dozen entities including barisma get
this according to another email obtained
by fox zero experience hunter
2017 requested that keys be made for his
quote
office mates he was referring to his dad
his uncle jim
and for space he planned to share with a
chinese business partner
so let's be clear now a full-fledged
foreign corruption scandal
and it implicates that guy let's ask the
obvious question are the bidens
compromised as it relates to
china ukraine russia remember the first
lady of moscow
elsewhere i wonder if these countries
have copies of hunter's laptop
our source is telling us what is on
there that we don't know yet is
devastating
it's not disinformation not hyperbole
not
hysteria it's all been hidden from the
public since 2018.
ask yourself why was the senate not made
aware of all this during that
quote impeachment trial with the hearsay
non-whistleblower whistleblower
why was all the relevant information
like the fbi being in possession of the
laptop
not part of the trial when it directly
dealt with the issue of foreign
corruption
and the president's call with president
zielinski don't forget joe biden's
actually on tape bragging about the
prosecutor he had fired
he's got six hours son of a bee they did
it and combine
all of that with what we already know
from senator ron johnson in the senate
committee
2013 peter schweitzer his book secret
empire
yep hunter biden flew aboard air force
two trip to china
ten days later hunter inked a sweetheart
deal ultimately 1.5
billion deal with the chinese
state-backed investment fund
no experience or qualifications we found
hunter also opened up a joint bank
account with the chinese national
connected to china's communist party
that same bank account would later fund
a shopping spree for hunter and his
family
2014 hunter gets three and a half
million wired a transfer from a corrupt
russian oligarch
remember the first lady in moscow former
ex-mayor of moscow's wife
again it's player little game place the
name hunter biden
or donald trump jr eric trump ivanka
trump
how do you think democrats the media mob
would cover it tiffany trump
if it wasn't just china russia because
in april 2014 a kazakh oligarch
wired over 140 grand a hunter biden's
firm
earmarked for a brand new car reality is
undeniable
hunter biden used his last name selling
access
now we gotta wonder what do they have on
him i wonder if they had pictures of the
crack pipe
here with react to it is wisconsin
senator ron johnson you have any
information on what's on that laptop
beyond what we know because
my source is telling me it's awful not
bad beyond awful
yeah i've heard some pretty bad rumors
as well but let's face it sean
this was well known in september when
senator grassley and i released our
report
peter schweitzer's book is reporting
this is not a surprise
i mean it's just amazing it's actually
galling but now it's post-election
and amazingly the mainstream media
recognizing hey you know this this
hunter biden story this is
this is probably worth investigating
it's it's really amazing
particularly when you realize the
national security threats are at stake
here
the extortion threats the
counterintelligence threats of their
connections with these chinese companies
with the individuals and connections to
the chinese communist party the people's
liberation army
and we talk about yeez jiaming we talk
about
don when don he's the guy that got the
the key but what about patrick ho
this is one of their associates was
convicted of foreign
corrupt practices act and money
laundering this is the guy when he was
arrested the first
call he was he placed was to james biden
which was a mistake he was really trying
to get hold of hunter
and i think hunter was paid something
like a million dollars unsuccessfully
defending him because patrick hoe spent
some time in jail
these are the people that the bidens
were associating with
and now we know uh another example of
how joe biden
had to know about these uh business
connections
these overseas business deals and he
lied
he lied to the american public about it
and he continues to lie
he's not being asked questions about it
all right
no argument for me russia is a hostile
regime the iranian muellers hate us
uh we know we have other enemies i think
china probably is the biggest threat of
all
what is the likelihood that based on
what we know and the deals that they've
done that they have compromising
materials on anybody in the biden family
that would concern me
well one of their companies was this
hudson west 3 there are a bunch of
hudson west companies
one two three four five i know in our
report we list about 150 million dollars
of wire transfers cash transactions
going back and forth
in 2017 and 2018 when vice president
biden's out of office now again i don't
know whether they had ownership interest
in that i know they had ownership
interest in hudson west three
but again it's the same same same
company name and of course that's the
company name
with the parentheses uh cefc
us that was supposed to be on the
signage of that
of that office space they leased and
shared the key with gangwon dong
today voting started in the in-person
voting early voting in georgia
how important are those two senate races
on january
5th to you being able to continue your
investigation with senator grassley
well it's crucial because if if we
retain them during the senate
chairman grassley i believe will become
chairman of the senate judiciary
committee again
i will become chairman of this permanent
subcommittee on investigations
and neither one of us have got to the
bottom of this
both of us are very frustrated with the
unfair
and biased treatment on the part of the
media the unfair and biased
suppression of information from these
agencies
uh and and of course the unequal system
of justice that we are witnessing in
this country it's shocking
senator i would like to see that work
continue and i think another outcome
would be they would undo
all the hard work that the president got
accomplished in four years
and if they had their way they would
probably invest investigate the entire
trump family in perpetuity
i don't think they'd ever stop senator
you've done great work here thank you